je sais il fait ce qu'il veut
là
il est tout le monde marilou berry
rachida brakni dalli laurent baffie
pascal bruckner bonne année aussi
quelle bonne résolution pour l'année
2005 les mêmes que le précédent les
trucs qu'on ne suis jamais des conneries
je vais faire des abdos je vais moins
picoler des trucs là noriko non je
picole fage fait des abdos dans comment
ils se la tête
non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai on fait
le choix des autres alors non non mais
on a envie de jeu les choses qu'on fait
marche
voilà ouais mais le bouquin il va
marcher là je sais pas si je sais pas
bah si alors justement c'est votre
nouveau roman pascal bourquin s'appelle
l'amour du prochain
c'est publié chez grasset alors le pitch
est le pitch un d'accord oui je le fais
je le fais tu veux le faire non je le
faire je rappelle que je le ferai au
sommet qui n'a pas du tout de sangle
abdominale mobilisation de 20 le sont et
il est dégoûté ce cas la deuxième leçon
la preuve qu'ils avaient bien se voir et
la base il a tu veux le faire le pitch
comme tu veux normative asie je vais
dire si tu es bon basique c'est donc
l'histoire c'est sébastien qui a 30 ans
bastien si solaire les chés bastien qui
a 30 ans il a tout il sera au
fonctionnaire au ministère des affaires
étrangères qui mariait qui est marié et
père de famille en avoir et qui le soir
de ses 30 ans aperçoit qu il a réussi sa
vie c'est à dire qu'il ya pratiquement
terminé sa vie parce qu'elle est elle
elle est parfaite
quand il fait le bilan de ses 30 ans
d'existence tout est positif
rien n'est mauvais il s'est dit pour
réussir ma vie si bien à 30 ans et que
quelque chose a raté et quelques jours
plus tard après cet anniversaire
il se trouve au café de la paix où il
attend un attaché culturel et il fait
très chaud et tout d'un coup le la
personne qui l'attend ne vient pas et
tout d'un coup il entend une voix sucrée
derrière lui c'est une femme qui lui dit
elle est en retard et se retourner y
voit une dame d'un certain âge qui
pourrait être sa mère trop bronzé trop
décolleté trop maquillée et s'est dit
mon dieu quelle horreur et la femme
safia sa table commence à l'entreprendre
il pense qu'il est tombé sur une
professionnelle parce que ça c'est pas
un petit chien si si
laurenti dans l'armée meilleur que le
pitch que j'aurais fait jusqu'ici été
meilleur que moi je connais un peu comme
et bientôt chez lui non mais toi tu dis
donc il est cette femme non plus
entreprend et commence à lui à lui poser
de questions il raconte sa vie il est
horrifié parce qu'ils voient que c'est
pas du tout une femme de son milieu ni
deux ni de deux de ses moeurs et un
moment la famille disent que ça vous
dirait de passer un petit moment avec
moi et donc il dit banon dont le côté
c'est pas du tout mon genre j'ai jamais
trompé ma femme est là elle pose de 100
euros sur la table et 10 pour ce prix là
ce que vous êtes d'accord ça le révulse
et prend l'argent ils eurent il remet
l'argent et il lui rend l'argent et au
moment il pose la main sur l'argent il
ya une érection formidable voilà et il
est il est horrifié parce qu'il dit
comment je peux être aussi divisés à la
fois refusé les propositions de cette
femme et en même temps avoir cette
excitation et lorsqu'elle s'aperçoit
qu'il est très émue elle remet 100 euros
sur la table et finalement il part avec
elle est donc l'histoire c'est le pitch
est un haut fonctionnaire du ministère
des affaires étrangères qui a 30 ans
réalise que sa vocation c'est d'être a
gigolo
voilà il décide de se prostituer il
s'aperçoit que se prostituer est
extrêmement difficile à bord faut
trouver un studio dont il ya un an avant
d'emménager et puis trouve pas de
clientes ses terres que tout le monde
dit que le corps est une marchandise de
personne ne veut de la sienne il ne veut
pas s'affilier à des réseaux de cole
boys et donc il met les petites annonces
qui sont catastrophiques parce que
personne n'y répond il mais plusieurs
mois avant d'avoir enfin une client qui
est une pharmacienne de poule vient
tromper son mari à paris est le deuxième
consommateur devient son consommateur et
peu à peu il se construit un réseau de
clientes et
il se vit comme comme un bienfaiteur il
est pas simplement un gigolo ne fais pas
ça pour l'argent parce qu'il n'a pas
besoin d'argent il fait vraiment ça pour
faire le bonheur des gens et il est il
leur parle des écoutes
il est il et consoles il les rassure et
il vit comme ça pendant trois ans dans
un bonheur parfait en divisant sa vie en
trois parties le matin ministère des
affaires étrangères où tout le monde
pense qui est certain c'est un
fonctionnaire modèle l'après-midi les
femmes qu'il reçoit chez lui le soir la
céni
oui raconte babar tintin à ses enfants
après avoir besogner trois ou quatre
personnes dans l'après-midi ira folle de
seddik loisonnais voile et ses
contrastes
voilà ça devrait vous intéresser parce
que votre mère a écrit la cliente
donc c'est juste le livre qui correspond
aussi à quoi on peut avoir les deux à la
maison ils se complètent parfaitement
1 voilà alors effectivement il rencontre
doha jeune jeune serveuse métis il ira
avec elle jusqu'au bout de sa passion sa
femme découvre le pot-aux-roses elle le
qui divorcent des chiens s'en passer une
histoire absolument terrible juste à une
chute qui est très inattendu un oui j'ai
voulu faire un apn parce que les
méchants il s'agira là évidemment mes
histoires c'est un éblouissement une
déchéance est finalement une
résurrection
parce qu'effectivement si j'avais fait
une chute tragique je serais allé dans
le sens actuel qui consiste à vous dire
la prostitution à nous expliquer que la
pierre des activités qu'elle conduit
inévitablement soit l'asile soit l'enfer
et j'ai voulu faire à piennes justement
pour briser un peu cette image
voilà ça vous tente la prostitution ça
dépend des institutions des hommes c'est
pas la même chose que les femmes parce
que les hommes c'est un d'un côté donner
du plaisir aux femmes marquent une femme
prostituée c'est un truc vite fait dans
une chambre ou disons une voiture un mec
c'est plus ça y est c'est un c'est bon
je trouve ça beaucoup plus sexy un métis
post situent plutôt qu'une femme
enfin après le concile doit y avoir des
femmes qui sont très sexy et qui font
des trucs très vivant de prostitution
quand j'avais fait chaos j'étais allé
sur les boulevards extérieurs avec les
avec les filles de l'est ça non
franchement non il ya des réflexions
très très très pertinentes comme ça il
épouse donc cette suzanne qui a fait hec
il fait trois enfants coup sur coup et
la fille dit j'ai le garçon il me faut
la fille et vous dites c'est un peu
comme si elle disait je vais machine à
laver une fois la chaîne laser quoi il
ya tout
parallèlement à l'histoire de ce garçon
il ya toute l'histoire de sa famille de
ses parents qui sont à l'archiviste
ancien trotskiste et qui évidemment ont
épousé tous les lieux communs donné à
gauche qu'on connaît aujourd'hui et et
sa femme qui veut faire de lui qui est
très ambitieuse kéké quand on sent
qu'elle est plus forte plus intelligente
que lui qui veut faire de lui un
diplomate à l'ambassadeur avant 40 ans
et donc elle le pousse constamment dans
ses études et et on sent que lui vit la
vie qui n'est pas la sienne vis à vis de
tout le monde et qu'à certains moments
il décroche l'or il ya des phrases comme
ça les gens vous disent toujours qu'ils
ont vécu une folle jeunesse en réalité
il s'agit d' excuses et une piteuse
maturité comme saviez des trucs très
très très très acide
par exemple au boulot il dit pour
réussir faut se faire enlever la colonne
vertébrale quoi il ya des idées comme ça
des notations qui sont très très
intéressante et donc effectivement il y
stade des vielles le climat se dégrade
et il dit avec sa femme et ils disent
quel merveilleux dans le couple c'est
qu'il vous protège de tout même de
l'amour
le vingtième siècle croit avoir inventé
de mariage d'amour mais on se rend
compte que si on veut baser une vie
conjugale simplement sur l'amour la
passion et la folie érotique
ça ne tient pas est ce que savait nos
ancêtres ici les gens restent ensemble
ce n'est pas simplement par pur amour ou
par désir c'est parce qu'il ya d'autres
valeurs qui rentrent en jeu et que
finalement on en revient un peu à la
sagesse de nos ancêtres qui savait que
le désir et la passion se vivait en
dehors du mariage le mariage bourgeois
quoi mais mickael mais oui ou non le
mariage classique le voyage des
aristocrates un hulu la femme et l'homme
avait des amants en dehors de la cellule
conjugale qui était simplement vouée à
la reproduction
vous pensez qu'on devra revenir l'âme
mes jambes et je pense qu'on aurait dit
aux crises y est je pense que je pense
qu'on a un discours à la fois sur la
sexualité et sur le mariage kiné qui en
porte à faux total penser que la société
madame vie dans un mythe qui est celui
de witti finalement va baiser pendant 40
ans ensemble avec le même plaisir celui
ce n'est pas vrai quoi comme le chichon
quoi faudrait légaliser
dlt saison mais de fait deux fait
effectivement d'abord l'adultère et de
complément du mariage comme il est comme
ça il a toujours été et nous amour
d'aujourd'hui ressemble beaucoup plus à
feydeau cas quelle image un peu héroïque
que nous en avons avec nous vivons une
société extrêmement sentimentale en
paroles 1 et qui en même temps vit sur
un mythe de la performance sexuelle
permanente qui ne correspond pas à la
vie des gens il ya vraiment un abîme
entre la manière dont nous nous voyons
nous décrivons et puisque vous racontent
les gens dans la dignité ce que disent
les psys et c'est beaucoup plus en même
temps c'est plus touchants mais c'est
beaucoup plus triste aussi
il ya une phrase c'est le mariage est
une guerre que deux personnes se livrent
pour se punir d'être ensemble
ah ben oui mais ça alors coûté si vous
connaissez les couples qui ont été
ensemble au delà de quelques années il
ya il ya quand même s'il ya des moments
extraordinaires ou où un homme et une
femme très unie très très tendre
plaidant pour la monogamie éclate en
imprécations et en horreur et vous
sentez que des derrière l'amour proclamé
ya désir de meurtre quoi parce que vivre
en couple vivre avec une personne c'est
exclure toutes celles où tout ce qu'on a
désiré cons et qu'on n'aura pas et donc
il ya certains moments on fait payer à
l'autre justement cette exclusion
alors on lui fait payer le fait de
n'être que lui-même et de ses tellement
vrai ski du truc imagine chez eux les
gens là qui ont baisé tout à l'heure
pour aller me disent qu'ils se détestent
mais une fois stérile et nous
commencions à touiller la souffrance des
rancoeurs domestique
oui bah ouais c'est ça tout à fait tout
à fait absolument oui alors hier les
faits qui voyait dans la aussi dans la
vie conjugale en même temps nous vivons
tous en couple
donc c'est que c'est probablement la
forme la plus la plus agréable delà de
la vie mais c'est vrai que le il ya une
sorte d'accumulation des griefs dans la
vie conjugale qui par moments a éclaté
on sent que l'un ou l'autre des
partenaires n'a oublié aucun tort qui a
été fait les gens vous ressort des
choses qui ont été faits il ya 5 6 ans
ya les dossiers c'est quand on monte la
petite cuillère
il ya quelque chose un petit peu du
préfet de police dans les coupes la
couche et j'ai ton dossier je te
préviens je leur sortirait dès qu'il en
ira alors votre héros lui pratiquer
l'amour du prochain c'est à dire ils
pratiquent la prostitution comme une
forme de charité chrétienne quoi ils
voient la cei donne de l'amour c'est un
nouvel évangile
alors il y là il est un principe
notamment c'est qu'il a exclu la
préférence c'est à dire que pour lui les
apparences physiques n'ont aucune
importance et il est ce qu'il ya de
merveilleux c'est qu'une idée c'est que
des inconnus lui donnent leur corps et
par conséquent il n'exclut personne ni
ligny lez vienne il est jeune il est
grossi les maigres bien et le mal tout
seul mais il se moque complètement de la
beauté des femmes qui vient qui viennent
le voir parce qu'ils pensent qu'elle du
moins tel cadeau en montant chez lui au
fond le reste m'indiffère complètement
mais à un moment il se lasse il en a
marre de ses clientes parce que les
clientèles sont vachement délurée elle
disant qu les comme on dit bonsoir
donc à un moment il a l'impression
d'être comme un cheval de chiffres dans
sa routine vous dites oui mais parce que
effectivement il ya un moment où tout
d'un coup ce métier le dégoûte un ce
qu'ils avaient vécu dans l'exaltation il
le matin il le vit dans le banc dans la
dépréciation et il s'aperçoit que
finalement la prostitution c'est aussi
une forme de vengeance contre et toutes
ces femmes qui lui mord d'auray et qu'il
embrasse qui lui susurre des obscénités
qui trouve totalement banale qui disent
parler finissent par l'indisposé et tout
ce qu'il veut c'est laisser les abattre
au point de faire de l'abattage tous
étaient là que tout est tarifié en fait
il ya selon lui un supplément c'est en
parla alors alors qu'au début l'argent
le lundi faire complètement là il
devient un programme il il est saisi par
le démon de la cupidité et alors ils ne
dépassent plus une certaine limite
d'heures donc il devient il vient à
tapas pelatan un vrai sapin avec ce que
ça de dureté de dead implacable pascal
c'est vrai que grasset à couper des
scènes scabreuses
oui parce que d'abord le livre était
très gros il est 500 pages et puis je
m'étais laissé à la mamé pente naturelle
la scatologie enfin le détail un peu le
ragoût tant que lune de fiel
l'un d'eux fiel effectivement grâce à on
a coupé beaucoup misé ont eu raison
parce que c'est ce type de licques et
toujours du sens à la hollande ça marche
bien à ce type de hiva toujours sur le
fil du rasoir quand on traite un sujet
et donc faut éviter les choses trop ou
un peu croquignolette ou qui peuvent
finalement rebuter le lecteur je trouve
ça marche mieux à l'allusion call
explicite vous avez des réactions
d'hommes de femmes et lecture du livre
oui j'ai pas mal de réactions plutôt
favorable dans l'ensemble mais aussi des
rejets très fort et très favorable chez
les femmes j'imagine tout favorable chez
huawei
les hommes il ya des passages qui les
rebute oui j'imagine que vous avez
enquêté pour faire ce livre sur les sur
les gigolos non non pas spécialement non
en quel nom pendant qu'il gérait
d'expériences personnelles
oui oui enfin je me suis mis le milieu
on m'a dit oui
non pas du tout enfin non mais je jouis
j'ai fait marcher ma mémoire
parce que là mais moi j'ai pas quelqu'un
par exemple un jeune téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent au fait j'ai demandé
combien gigolo par exemple il faut viser
les femmes de quel âge là bas ça je peux
pas vous répondre mais il ya des femmes
de tout âge il ya beaucoup de femmes
d'affaires qui ont recours à des call
boys quand elles sont en déplacement en
fait et moi je trouve assez scandaleux
que les hommes puissent aller voir des
prostituées à n'importe quel moment dans
n'importe quel endroit de la porte de
n'importe quelle ville du monde et que
la même chose ne sera pas autorisé aux
femmes mais je trouve que plutôt que de
vouloir abolir la prostitution qui est
d'ailleurs un effort généralisé il faut
la généraliser détendre de chalosse et
offrir aux femmes des maisons de
libertinage où elles pourront satisfaire
les caprices de bien sûr parce que ce
qu'on ne dit pas c'est que la femme une
sexualité beaucoup plus riche que la
note ne nous sommes assez mécanique
finalement l'homme est assez pauvre
sexuellement trika femme à une diversité
et une possibilité de jouissance qui est
bien supérieure à la nôtre est un
spectacle deux fois ils s'attendent à
que vous rencontriez avec les actrices
actuelles du psg des soirées comme ça à
gré à auteuil qui est antipathique et
des soirées comme ça qui fonctionne mais
alors il faut demander combien
si on veut je ne sais pas mais je pense
que les tarifs vont de 100 à 500 euros
voilà et 500 euros c'est bien dit long
je pose pour 500 euros vous avez droit
des raffinements des égards à l'égard
des gars fait pas c'est vrai c'est
important de la voilà ça s'appelle
l'amour du prochain c'est chez grasset
ça vous intéresse
ouais moi pas trop ça devrait vous
attend chez dc un prix de départ si tu
lâches qui l'a bloqué
le label l'amour du prochain on va faire
une interview par amour du prochain